[Music]
hello everyone welcome to the langfocus
channel and my name is paul today's
topic is the amharic language or
ahmadinya as it's known in amharic
amharic is one of the major languages of
ethiopia and it's the official working
language of the ethiopian federal
government regional and local
authorities are free to choose their
working language in ethiopia but amharic
is the working language of several
regions according to the 2007 census
it's the native language of 22 million
people or around 30 percent of the
population of 74 million but over the
last 10 years the population of ethiopia
is thought to have surpassed 100 million
and the number of native amharic
speakers is probably over 30 million but
ethiopia is a country where many people
are multilingual and millions more
people speak amharic as a second
language especially in cities and towns
amharic is a member of the semitic
language family which also includes
hebrew arabic aramaic and the tigre and
tagrenya languages which are spoken in
ethiopia and eritrea
all semitic languages developed from the
theoretic proto-semitic language
the ethiopic or ethiosemitic languages
are part of the south semitic branch and
the most common theory is that all
ethiosomatic languages including amharic
developed from a common proto-ethio
semitic language this proto-ethiosemitic
language is thought to have developed
from the language of migrants from
southern arabia presumably old south
arabian languages these migrants
intermixed with the native people who
spoke cucitic languages and
proto-ethiosemitic arose this language
was a direct descendant of the language
of the migrants from this
proto-ethiosemitic language two branches
developed the southern branch which
includes amharic and the northern branch
which includes tigre tigrenia and gaies
the oldest attested ethiosimidic
language and the one that became the
official language of the axomite empire
and remained the official literary
language in ethiopia until the 19th
century some believe in that theory of
migration from southern arabia but some
believe that amharic developed from a
semitic language that had existed in the
area before that migration
and in recent years another theory has
arisen that amharic is actually a creole
that arose from contact between
semitic-speaking officers and
kushidik-speaking soldiers in the
aksamite empire after the 4th century
but this theory is hotly contested and
is not the general consensus the
earliest known amharic writing is from
the 13th century even though it was
mainly a spoken language at that time
this was the time of the solomonic
dynasty when king yakuno amlak made
amharic the spoken lingua franca of the
ethiopian court and it became known as
the language of the king
the language of the previous axomite
rulers continued to be used as the
language of literature
this resulted in a diglossic situation
that would last for centuries with gaes
being used for literature and in the
ethiopian orthodox church and amharic
being used in speech in the 15th century
under the rule of zadayakov troops who
collected taxes for the king likely
brought amharic into other regions
further south
in the mid-19th century amharic began to
replace gays as the literary language
case in point the ethiopian emperors
theodos ii and minilike ii had their
chronicles written in amharic rather
than gays which had been used for
previous emperors under minilike ii
ethiopia grew into something resembling
its current borders amharic became the
de facto official language and amharic
speaking officials were responsible for
the newly incorporated territories the
spread of the printing press in the 19th
and 20th centuries contributed further
to the spread of amharic as in the 20th
century most new print materials
including the first newspaper were
written in amharic rather than gaze in
the early 20th century italian french
and english were used as the main
languages of school instruction but then
in 1944 amharic became the sole language
of instruction in primary schools under
the rule of haila selassie he then made
amharic the official language of
ethiopia in 1955. during the socialist
government known as the derg from 1974
to 1991 increased development
urbanization and an increase in the
number of public schools and adult
literacy programs caused them hurric to
spread even more but still amharic was
much more widely spoken in towns and
cities and not as widely spoken in rural
areas except in its original native
regions after 1991 language policies
were changed to give more influence to
the other languages of ethiopia and
there are over 80 of them currently
regional and local authorities can
choose their own working language and
their own language of primary school
education but amharic remains the most
widely spoken lingua franca with a large
proportion of the urban population
throughout the country being able to
speak amharic so what is amharic like
first of all what's this interesting
script that amharic is written in well
that's actually the geys script which is
used not only to write the gaes language
but also amharic tigrinya and others the
ge script is an abugida each character
represents a syllable and consists of a
consonant as its major component plus an
attached ligature or other modification
that represents a vowel in amharic this
gaze-based writing system is called
fidel
in amharic there are plane consonants
similar to most of the consonants in
english and there are glottalized
consonants or ejective consonants
glottalized consonants are produced by
closing and reopening the glottis the
space between your vocal cords while
making the consonant sound when
transliterated using latin characters
they usually have a dot underneath them
to distinguish them from their
non-glottalized equivalents let's
compare a plane consonant with its
glottalized equivalent
also notice the doubled consonant
all consonants can be short or long long
meaning that the consonant is doubled
double in length the distinction between
short and long consonants is important
because sometimes the meaning of words
is distinguished by the length of the
consonant for example
this means he said
this means there is
this means swimming
this means important
so in both cases the length of the
consonant distinguishes the meaning of
the words doubled consonants are not
distinguished in writing but in context
amharic speakers have little trouble
with that
sentence structure
first let's look at an equational
sentence using the verb to be
this means the boy is short word for
word it's boy the short is
oo is a definite article lege is boy
is the boy notice that the verb to be is
at the end and the adjective comes
before it
amharic is a verb final language so in
predicative sentences the word order is
sv or ov or sov of course some sentences
have no object just a subject and an
intransitive verb for example
this sentence means the child fell word
for word is child the he fell so this is
the subject and this is the verb
and here's a sentence that does have a
direct object
it means the hunter killed a lion word
for word it's hunter the lion he killed
here's the subject the object and the
verb
something we can add to this sentence is
the optional direct object marker
if you use the direct object marker then
it's also possible to place the object
at the beginning of the sentence making
it osv
god and now let's try adding an
adjective to this sentence
this sentence now means the hunter
killed a big lion and you can see that
the adjective is placed before the noun
the previous sentences all have an
explicit subject but there can also be
no explicit subject for example this
sentence meaning he opened the door
word for word it's door the direct
object marker he opened no explicit
subject is necessary here because we
know from the form of the verb that it
refers to the third person masculine
singular he so this sentence is just ov
object verb
and that brings us to verbs
similar to in other semitic languages
the verb consists of a stem and suffixes
which indicate the person gender and
number of the subject let's take a look
at this example verb meaning to break
here's the stem of the perfect form and
the suffixes placed after the stem tell
us about the doer of the action
now let's look at the imperfect form
based on this stem
the root system let's take a look at the
stems of the perfect form and the
imperfect form again and let's focus on
these letters here
similar to in other semitic languages
amharic uses a system of root letters
and templates into which the root
letters are inserted roots consist of
consonants commonly three but it could
also be two four or five and they are
placed into templates consisting of a
vowel pattern as well as some
consonantal affixes
the root gives us the core meaning and
the template gives us grammatical
information and more specific
information about the meaning notice
that with this verb the second root
letter is doubled or geminated in the
perfect form this is true for some verbs
but not for others
those are a few of the important
features of amharic let's look at a few
more example sentences and see what else
we find here's a sentence meaning we
must go today sorry
word for word it's today to go we must
in this sentence we see a modal verb
meaning must just like other verbs this
modal verb is conjugated for the subject
in this case we the modal verb comes at
the end and before that we see the main
verb meaning to go in its infinitive
form
another sentence
this means where can i find a doctor
word for word it's doctor where is found
the word hakim is the same as the arabic
word for doctor and i would guess that
this is a loanword this word means where
question words usually come directly
before the verb and you can see that the
object of the verb comes first this is
an imperfect verb with these root
consonants the affixes show that this is
the third person singular form
and on to the next sentence
this means i've lost my car keys word
for word it's of car my key have been
lost to me
this pattern here of plus a noun plus
another noun is a typical way of showing
possession or connection between two
nouns and this is a verb with these two
root consonants which mean to lose but
this particular verb template makes it
reflexive or intransitive so it means to
be lost this is the conjunct form of the
verb which can be used like the present
perfect in english and this ending here
means something like happened to me
showing that the speaker is affected by
the action notice that in this sentence
the word for key is singular plural can
often be understood from the context
even if you use the singular form but we
can also use an explicit plural form
again this means i've lost my car keys
but here you can see that a plural
ending has been added to the word for
key but it's not entirely necessary to
use the plural form you can use the
singular form and in context it should
be clear whether you're talking about
just one or many
and on to the next sentence
this means we love ethiopian cuisine
word for word it's of ethiopia food we
love again we see that pattern showing
possession or relationship between two
nouns and here we see the imperfect form
of the verb meaning to love here's the
stem and here are the affixes telling us
that this is first person plural in
other words the we form
and one more sentence
this means i didn't break the vase
conjugation in amharic there's a special
negative perfect form of verbs the
negative form is made by adding this
prefix and this suffix to the regular
perfect form and here's the word for
vase and here the definite article
suffix but since it's following another
vowel it's written as
rather than
as a semitic language amharic has some
vocabulary that overlaps with other
semitic languages like hebrew and arabic
some of these similar words are
loanwords from other languages like
arabic or gays but some are cognates
that developed from a common ancestor as
the words in other semitic languages and
sometimes it's hard to know if the word
is a loanword or an original cognate
for example the word we saw before which
means break
the same third person perfect form in
hebrew would be shava and in hebrew
sometimes the second root letter like a
v sound is doubled and pronounced like a
b sound which makes the similarity even
more obvious
and we also saw the word to kill
this is the third person perfect form in
hebrew it's katal meaning to slay or to
kill in arabic it's
the consonants here are not exactly the
same but i think there's a connection
between the g sound and amharic and the
ka or ka sounds in the other languages
and i think there's a connection between
the d and the t sounds in the other
languages another example the word for
berry
in hebrew it's kavar
and in arabic
in amharic the verb meaning to hear is
semma and this is the third person
perfect form meaning he heard in hebrew
it's shama in arabic it's sama in hebrew
and arabic there's an extra root letter
that was lost in the amharic word and it
has mostly become silent in modern
hebrew but it's still written
in amharic the word for i is iron in
hebrew it's in and in arabic it's ein i
would love to be able to say that the
english word i is related to those but
it's not
another one in amharic there's beet
which means house in hebrew it's bait
but when it's used in a compound word
with another noun it's pronounced bait
like in beit sephi the word for school
in arabic it's bait or bait
but the amount of vocabulary that
amharic has in common with hebrew and
arabic might be less than you'd expect
that's partly because a lot of the
vocabulary is of cushitic origin as much
as 30 percent and other vocabulary is
unique to amharic or to ethiosomatic
amharic is a very interesting language
and it's a language with clearly semitic
features including the verbal system and
the root system using consonantal roots
and inserting them into templates those
are things i'm familiar with from other
semitic languages like hebrew and arabic
and that includes some of the vocabulary
we just looked at a second ago but some
elements are quite different from other
semitic languages such as its sov word
order amharic is a language that i would
love to dig into more in the future at
some point
in my last video on japanese i forgot to
ask a question of the day so today i'm
not gonna forget here is the question of
the day for speakers of amharic how
widely is amharic spoken in your area
and your community and if you're an
immigrant from ethiopia living somewhere
else in the world what language do
members of your community normally speak
with each other
and for speakers of other semitic
languages have you noticed the
similarities between amharic and your
language what sorts of similarities have
you noticed be sure to follow langfocus
on facebook twitter and instagram and
once again i want to say thank you to
all of my patreon supporters especially
these wonderful people right here on the
screen for their monthly pledges thank
you for watching and have a nice day
[Music]
[Music]
you